what is up everybody happy Monday
morning welcome to another gratitude
Journal livestream number 11 the idea
here is we spend a couple minutes every
morning at 9:00 a.m. Eastern to share
things that we were grateful for
gratitude is one of the keys to
happiness and it's hard to be upset and
be grateful at the same time and as an
entrepreneur we've got a ton of crappy
stuff that we have to deal with and yes
being passionate gets us through but
also being grateful for what we do have
being equally you know uncomfortable and
wanting more and wanting to push but
also on the other hand grateful for what
we do have and recognize that we already
have a pretty amazing life quicker than
most people in the world it's important
so I do this with my team I'm bringing
it to you guys the two most important
facts or parts of it one is that its
daily it's a consistent habit it's every
single day and the second is that you
really feel it and not just list things
off you get the benefits you have to
feel it you got to be a part of it you
got a it's got a touch you've got to get
a little emotional thinking about it
otherwise you don't get the benefit so
I'm gonna go through three things in
iron grateful for I want you guys in the
live chat to share three things you're
grateful for you guys watching after the
fact leave it in the comments down below
three things you're grateful for do that
consistently and you will be a happier
and I think more successful
entrepreneurs so I'm gonna go first
three things for me
I'm grateful for it I'm grateful for
just life you know going met on this one
but on the weekend yesterday Jose
Fernandez passed away for those of you
who aren't baseball fans he was a
pitcher for Miami he was 24 years old
one of the best pitchers in the game his
whole life ahead of them and he died in
a boating accident and I remember I was
getting on the elevator in my condo here
and it just flashed it on the news what
that's really really bad I mean you know
his
girlfriend is pregnant and anyway just a
super sad story and from watching you
know other people's sadness I guess it
gives a little bit of puts the world in
perspective right like I'm alive you
know I'm pretty healthy I have my
parents there's my wife she has her
parents you know everybody's relatively
healthy which is great and maybe think
about Buddhists who meditate on
suffering and the suffering leads to the
meditation on suffering at what could
happen
makes you a little more grateful for
what you have right now and happier and
more peaceful in the present state and
so it's true that we can learn from the
suffering of others and so anyway super
sad about Jose Fernandez and over the
weekend was just thinking how great
volume to be alive and not have some
freak voting accident take someone away
from me that that is important it's a
heavy one is a heavy one to start with
Monday morning that's a heavy one number
two for me I would say is uh Hayden's
not caring what other people think you
know I I wonder where he gets that from
but we went Halloween costume shopping
for him for for Halloween on the weekend
and we ended up getting this costume
that's just like evil court jester thing
and he insisted on wearing it and I
always supported that like yeah let's
you want to wear it let's do it and so
he got on the elevator at the condo in
full outfit and everybody's looking at
him like who is this person dressed up
like a court jester and somebody said in
the elevator do you know it's not
Halloween or something's like I don't
care and I loved it I was a hostess I
loved that I didn't care that people
thought and I'm trying to kind of
nurture that I guess to inside him and
he's just picked it up with just just
full-on so not hating is not caring what
other people think he's gonna go do his
own thing
I love it and then the third thing for
me would be Nina's Nina's understanding
we had a pretty busy week lots of stuff
happening during the week and so on the
weekend I booked us tickets to go to the
Toronto Home Show which is this annual
thing where they have everything related
to homes houses you know interior design
anything about the house basically it's
that the big Convention Center downtown
in we went and it was supposed to be our
you know our thing to do to relax unwind
and be together and have fun learn
something new and it was super boring
it's one of the last time we show we're
gonna go to just super boring way
smaller than it used to be just not a
great vibe about it and nothing was
interesting at least for us where we're
at with our place and and I felt bad
that this was supposed to be our thing
you know that we were gonna enjoy and
have you know some relaxing time
together and and it didn't deliver and
Nina was like it's okay yeah it's just
pretty calm and understanding and
religious as long as we're spending time
together it was good and when did off
leaving and going doing other things but
some people are really good with changes
and not putting too much hopes I guess
and there's something are not being too
let down when something doesn't happen
their way or they can see it from a
different perspective and another's
can't you know that could have easily
been a really negative situation and it
ended up being a pretty positive one so
I'm really grateful for for my wife's
understanding so you guys are wrapping
that but we got four four minutes
there's no leagues livestream chat after
today guys I'm sorry I gotta take care
of some stuff but we're gonna do four
minutes of listening to you guys and for
those you after again leaving the
comments below rishi kept TV what's up
Rasheed I'm grateful
for number one my morning pages
journaling I haven't done it myself but
if people seem to enjoy that so thank
you for sharing number two to wake up
this morning and begin again number
three that it's not about perfection but
showing up and just being yourself hash
that cup of love I love it
Zayn oh hey y'all hey Z know people for
my ankles the body part of the day is a
knows ankles for allowing me to walk run
and jump they failed me more than a few
times but they're mostly doing a great
job happy face number two nice warm
showers after basketball practice and
games we played our second game of the
season yesterday awesome some really
basketball season I like it I like
basketball in the off season number
three my fridge for keeping cold
whatever needs to be cold you know
grateful that you have a fridge right
the things that we don't we don't think
about that we just take for granted
having a fridge is an amazing thing Jay
Rhys thankful for loving friends who
make time for us when we need them for
genius innovators who move entire
industries for clean clear flowing
breath and life I'm lovin Jay Rhys added
some love here much oh I skipped a bunch
much for my silly kitty a silly kitty
silly Keeley silly kitty
adela whose watch is with me right now
what is up Adela
what do we need to do for a cat cat
they're like I need a little laser or
something to pop on the screen for
people for the cat to chase around
anyway what's up Adela much is also
people for water miracle liquid I love
it
much also know loves the morning pages
much as a writer so it's good to get
that out
Russia cup says that's beautiful Nina
flexibility L addressee Medi hi Evan I'm
grateful because I think that I'm
open-minded much love for Morocco I love
that much love back to you from Toronto
we she's saying hey much is doing
giggles you guys are all loving each
other huh kitty
becoming a suspect I wonder if I put I
don't have I have we have a family dog I
guess the cat wouldn't like the family
dog picture that's a bad call I feel
like they need to have something how
about I have a tea bag about the tea bag
my nettle tea if I like swing it it's
not gonna get the cat following are you
guys following you are you being
hypnotized into a gratitude low cool
well we're at time thank you guys so
much for all the love have an amazing
day
again no live stream today but in the
league but we're back on tomorrow for
those of you again watching after don't
just watch the video take action leave
three things below that you are grateful
for put it in there and you do that
consistently you'll be a much happier
entrepreneur enjoy the rest of the week
guys and during the start of the week
have an amazing week continue to believe
or whatever you're one where it is and
I'll see you soon